hi in our itcs paper on fixed parameter
sensitivity oracles we are proposing a
new research direction by combining
ideas from two areas that were
previously disjoint
the first search area is that of
sensitivity oracles where we want to
maintain the graph property under edge
values
in this example we have certain pairs of
vertices and the shortest paths between
them and it might be that if some edge
fails in that graph that the distance
between these vertices increase and we
want to prepare for that
specific to sensitivity is that all edge
failures arrive at once
but we know their maximum number f which
is this sensitivity
this is also the main difference to
dynamic graphs
where the edge modifications arrive one
by one but are potentially unbounded in
number
and to get a sensitivity oracle we want
to
pre-process the graph once into a small
data structure that is then queried when
needed a query is a set of at most f
edges and we get its answer the property
of that graph where the specified edges
fail
and classically sensitivity oracles are
researched for properties that are
polynomial time computable
for example all paired distances the
connectivity of that graph or certain
reachability questions
but of course some graph properties are
not polynomial time computable but at
least some of them are fixed parameter
tractable
that means the graph comes augmented
with some integer parameter k
and if we restrict our attention to
graphs
with that parameter
then the property is computable in time
some function of that parameter
times a polynomial in the graph size
so the
textbook example is if we only care
about the vertex cover of size at most k
then we compute it if one exists in time
2 to the k times k times linear in the
graph size so we can find the
combinatorial explosion of that problem
solely to the parameter and if we fix k
to a certain value hence the name
the whole algorithm becomes linear time
and it does not matter whether we fix k
to 2 or 42.
and we observe that many fpt algorithms
are some kind innate fault tolerant so
for example in this standard branching
algorithm in the same time bound it does
not only compute a single vertex cover
but all of them
from a decision point of view this is
redundant because we can just stop as
soon as we find one solution
but this redundancy can also be
interpreted
as some kind of fault tolerance
and we propose fault tolerance
sensitivity oracles to make this
connection rigorous
these are data structures with
sensitivity f
for fpt graph properties
to make that clear
as answer of our oracle we want
the property of
the graph where the specified edges fail
with the same parameter k so we keep k
fixed for all queries
as pre-processing time we want some
function of f and k times some fixed
polynomial that is independent of f and
k
so if you survil an fpt preprocessing
time in f plus k
what we do not want is something
essentially n to the f
times some function of k
because we could just get this by uh
going through all failure sets and
computing the fpt probability for each
of them
and storing the answer so this does not
give us anything above the trivial
solution
and as query time we want something that
is significantly faster than computing
the property from scratch
again we want to be better than the
trivial solution of storing the whole
graph and just running the fpt algorithm
but of course this bar is highly
dependent on the property and what is
currently known how to compute it
the idea to transform fpt also to other
areas is not entirely new
probably closest to our work is fpt for
dynamic graphs which was started by
iwata and occur
they
discussed the vertex cover and cake path
problem
in a dynamic setting parameterized by
the solution size
which will also be the examples in my
talk
the results were further developed by
elmer and nick and mozilla williams
and recently chennai transferred this
also to other parameters
most notably the tree depth they showed
how to dynamically maintain
an elimination forest which is used to
define tree bath
but none of these works
discuss the setting where the
sensitivity f is fixed
so they do it for dynamic graphs but not
in the sensitivity setting
also what is interesting there is one
itcs work by uh lagrete i from two years
ago
they started out with a classical fault
tolerant problem namely fault tolerant
reachability
and we're looking for a graph class
where they can get rid entirely of the
dependence on the original graph size so
they ended up with
update times
only dependent on the sensitivity f
and they found it in so-called bounded
independence number graphs and then they
took this graph class
back to fpt and showed
that also some parametrized problems
that are usually hard on general graphs
admit fpt algorithms on this special
graph class
so they took inspiration from fault
tolerance and took it back to fpt so
essentially the other way around
as i said the first example problem
we're discussing is that of vertex cover
where we want to know whether the graph
with the specified edge failures emits
the vertex cover of size at most k
with the current best algorithm this can
be computed in time
1.274 to the k plus k times n
so this is the
bar we have to meet for our query time
and the first thing we showed is that
some kind of kernelization also applies
in default tolerance setting in the
sense that in polynomial time you can
compute a
graph whose size only depends on k and f
such that if you fail the same edges in
the original and in the equivalent graph
then one has a vertex cover of size at
most k if and only if the other one has
this is already very nice because then
the
space consumption and the query time of
all of our data structures
the
is independent of the graph size there
but still we have to careful
carefully trade off between space
pre-processing and query time depending
on those two parameters f and k
this is something we inherit from the
sensitivity oracles where usually not
one
data structure is best for all settings
it really depends on whether you
emphasize a small space or a fast
pre-processing or query time
and here we also have this two
parameters f at k
and in this talk i will make the
simplifying assumption that the
parameter f is smaller than k
this
helps with writing down the results
later
in the paper we also have results for f
larger than k
but still i don't make any assumption on
how much smaller f is compared to k and
dependent on their relative size
different solutions might be better
in our first solution we get a space of
3 to the f plus k so independent of the
graph size
and it can be computed in time
essentially proportional to its space
plus the polynomial preprocessing and
has a query time of 2 to the f
so entirely independent of k
so we get a rid of this k and the
graph size in the query time
we obtained this
i hinted it earlier that the
standard branching is in some sense
fault tolerant you can just add the this
edge fails option in the branching tree
and get the solution one
this is what you want to do essentially
if you only prepare for a few edges but
for a large parameter larger vertex
cover of size k
but still you might take issue in an
exponential dependence on f
so in our second solution we bring the
query time down to k square
there is some dependence on f hidden in
there but with the simplifying
assumption that f is smaller than k this
is subsumed by k square but it is
polynomial in the parameters
but we pay for this improvement
somewhere else
namely in the space and the
pre-processing time
which has this
k-squared term in the exponent which
then for a large k might be much larger
than this 3 to the k
which we initially had here
we get this by combining the branch and
bound technique which is frequently used
for exact exponential algorithms and
therefore also for fpt
together with fault tolerant lookup
trees that then guarantees this fast
pre-processing time sorry this fast
query time in terms of k
but still you might
look for some solution that only has
polynomial space so avoiding this
exponential dependency on f and k in the
space
there our third solution comes in which
is a simple adaption of what emma and
mission resolve williams did for dynamic
graphs it has space k squared so
polynomial in the parameter
which might even be smaller than storing
the whole graph
but it has a query time of
1.274 to the k this is essentially
running a vertex cover algorithm
from scratch
we save this dependence on the graph
size but still the query time is
exponential in k
in order to get this
small space
in our second example problem
we are discussing k path which is the
question whether the
graph with specified edge failures has a
simple path of length k our solution
work both for directed and undirected
graphs
the fastest deterministic algorithm is
running in time
2.554 to the k times some polynomial
and if you allow randomization you can
do it in
1.657 to the k times polynomial
this
this problem is a prototype essentially
for all kinds of parameterized path
problem
because classically in
sensitivity oracles you discuss
distances or shortest paths so a lot of
techniques
are already developed to preserve paths
on the
edge failures and we can use this for
example for the k-path problem but also
for other parameterized path problems
there unfortunately the classical
colonization is not robust to
fault tolerant it's not fault tolerant
so we get this polynomial dependence on
the graph size also in the size of the
solution
in our first
solution we get
um
space k to the f plus one
with the randomized preprocessing of k
to the f times
this
1.65 to the k times polynomial
but at least we get super fast query
time of f square
again independent of k end of the graph
size
we obtain this by uh using a fault
tolerant lookup tree of death
where each of these nodes hold the k
pass so this is essentially k to the f
plus
times k which is the size of that k path
this
then allows us to bring down the query
time significantly but of course these
trees are huge
so we also thought about a solution that
brings down this space
and indeed we can essentially trade this
k to the f factor here
for some factor s which is this
beautiful expression
this is um
much smaller than k to the f to give you
some intuition in the worst case for f
equal to k this is
essentially 2 to the f plus k times f
times logarithmic
so we really bring down the space
and
also the
um
pre-processing time
but unfortunately this s also creeps in
in the query time so we pay um this
space reduction
by
significantly improving increasing the
query time
we get this second solution
by sampling as subgraphs of g
by in each one of them discarding each
edge independently with probability f
divided by f plus k
and then if you do the math with high
probability for every failure set and k
path if one survives there is one
subgraph where this combination happens
together this is a
technique frequently used in
sensitivity analysis introduced by
rayman industry
but yeah the problem is that you then
have to go through all the s subgraphs
to find the one you're looking for
so so far we showed
different example problems for
where we can obtain sensitivity oracles
with the help of fpt
for the rest of my talk i want to
speak about the opposite direction
where
parameterization can help in fault
tolerant
so as an example we have fault tolerant
distance preservers
if you remember my drawing from the
beginning
uh we don't now have not pairs of
vertices but a single source vertex s
and we care about the distances from s
to all target vertices t
and the fault tolerant distance
preserver is then a sub graph of g
um such that for all
target vertices is t
and for all at most f h failures
we have that if you fail these same
edges in the original graph and in the
subgraph the distance from s to t gets
preserved
meaning essentially that we want to
specify the graph g
while still maintaining the fault
tolerant information about the distances
from s
and there are
known solutions with essentially n to
the 2
minus 1 divided by 2 to the f many edges
and also you cannot do much better in
terms of the graph size in that there is
a lower bound
of n to the 2 minus 1 divided by f plus
one
so for a large number of failures you
essentially have to do with a quadratic
number of edges in this
fault tolerant preservatives
you cannot specify the graph by too much
but what happens
if you only care about those distances
that do not get disturbed by too much
in the sense that for any set of at most
f failures
you at most get an additive term of k
so we only care about distances that do
not get perturbed by too much and this
too much is
governed by this parameter k
then we showed that you can obtain
distance preservers with
some function of f and k
times a linear number of edges
so indeed especially for small values of
f and k
we can significantly improve above the
lower bound
by relaxing the objective to only those
distances that
don't
get disturbed by too much
and we also give an oracle
that tells these two cases apart so that
reports for a given
failure set and the given target vertex
t
whether the distance is only increased
by this additive k
and
we get the solution that has space 2 to
the k times k squared times n squared
in
preprocessing that uses fast matrix
multiplication
notably both the space and the
pre-processing time are independent of
the number of failures so you can really
do this for a large number of failures
if you want to
the query time does depend on f
but is at least independent of the
graph size
and we obtain this solution by reducing
the question of whether the fault
tolerant distance increases by at most k
to some reachability question and then
applying a non-reachability sensitivity
oracle by fandenbrand and saranurak from
2019.
so the main message here is that
if you are willing to relax the
objective and parameterize it then you
can really improve upon known lower
bounds for the general problem
so to wrap up
we observed that fixed parameter
tractable algorithms are often already
fault tolerant or allowed to be made so
with only small changes
and the sensitivity f fits natural to
the parametrized setting
but still
we have to make careful trade-offs
between space pre-processing time and
query time
to obtain sensible
solutions but
we also think that parameterization can
help relax some bottlenecks in classical
fault tolerant problems
so we hope to
continue this direction further and
for some new research
direction listing open problems is
essentially everything is open
but the most important things here would
be to extend fixed parameter sensitivity
oracles for more fpt probabilities and
see what else we can do there
and
for the existing solutions bring down
the exponential dependencies on f and k
usually you can get rid
or diminish the dependency on the graph
size that is fine
but
still currently we have huge
dependencies on f and k that
must be improved
and lastly it would be interesting to
see more fault tolerant problems that
can benefit from parameterization where
you can relax maybe the objective a bit
in order to sidestep non-lower bounds
and with these words
i thank you for your attention